digamos esta vez que queremos encontrar
cuánto es 500 entre 200 pausa este vídeo
y ve si puedes encontrar la respuesta
bien una estrategia para hacer esto es
simplemente volver a expresar esta
división como una fracción y ver si
pueden simplificar esta fracción en una
manera que sea sencilla de expresar como
un decimal entonces por ejemplo esto va
a ser lo mismo que 500 sobre 200 y ahora
observa podemos simplificar esto porque
esto es exactamente lo mismo que tener
5%
sobre 2% y la razón de por qué esto es
útil es debido a que ahora podemos decir
mira tengo un 100 en el numerador y
tengo un 100 en el denominador y
entonces 100 entre 100 va a ser igual a
1 así que solamente podemos fijarnos en
cuánto es cinco medios observa esto es
igual a 5 sobre 2 por 100 sobre 100 y
100 sobre 100 esto va a ser igual a 1 o
tal vez otra forma de plantearlo es
dividir el numerador y el denominador
entre 100 y al final nos vamos a quedar
con 5 siempre que dividan el numerador y
el denominador entre lo mismo no están
cambiando el valor de la fracción iv en
el denominador me va a quedar
simplemente 2 así que cualquier manera
en la que lo plantee en eso podría
simplificarse a 5 medios
pero no hemos terminado aún eso es
equivalente a 500 entre 200 y ahora la
pregunta va a ser si esto lo podemos
escribir en forma de un decimal bien
podemos volver a escribir cinco medios
como un número mixto entonces cinco
medios va a ser igual
y bueno cuántas veces entre dos en cinco
bueno entra dos veces y sobra uno por lo
tanto va a quedar un médium esto va a
ser igual a dos enteros y un medio y
ahora habrá forma de expresar dos
enteros un medio común decimal bueno
puedes recordar ser que este un médium
es lo mismo que cinco decimos entonces
esto va a ser igual a dos enteros y
cinco decimos que por supuesto podemos
escribirlo como 2.5 o dos enteros y 5
decimos muy bien entonces ya podemos
decir que 500 entre 200 es 2.5 ahora
hagamos otro ejemplo digamos que esta
vez queremos hacer
ocurren 0.63 / 0.07 pausa el vídeo y ver
si puedes encontrar o proponer una
estrategia para resolver esto bueno hay
varias maneras de solucionarlo una
manera es plantear ambos números en
términos de centésimos por ejemplo
observen 0.63 es lo mismo que 63
centésimos y 0.07 bueno esto es lo mismo
que 7 centésimos y entonces si tienen 63
de algo y lo están dividiendo entre 7 de
ese mismo algo que van a obtener bueno
si tomas sus 7 centésimos y lo
multiplicas por 9 vas a obtener 63
centésimos
entonces 63 de algo entre 7 del mismo
algo va a ser igual a 9 esto va a ser
igual a 9 bien esta es una forma de
plantear la otra forma de plantearlo es
la siguiente poder expresar esto como
una fracción en donde tenemos un
numerador de 0.63
y el denominador de 0.07 y si los
decimales nos incomodan podemos
multiplicar tanto el numerador como el
denominador por el mismo valor para
deshacernos de los decimales así que qué
te parece si multiplicamos el numerador
por 100 y también multiplicamos el
denominador por 100 ojo esto no va a
cambiar el valor de expresión ya que
multiplicando por 100 sobre 100 es lo
mismo que multiplicar por 1 así que esto
va a ser igual a amd 0.63 por 100
bien como veríamos el punto decimal 2 a
la derecha y me quedaría que esto es
igual a 63 sobre 0.07 por 100 una vez
más movemos el punto decimal dos veces
hacia la derecha y esto me va a quedar 7
entonces tengo simplemente 63 entre 7 lo
cual ya sabemos que es igual a 9